In Cycle 5 we will try to issue this next instruction which is a divide.
This divide is going to look for this type of a unit and find it, so
we're going to mark that ML2 is not four. We are going to say that this is
issued in Cycle 5. We're going to look at F0 and F6 as our inputs. F0 comes from
ML1. F6 is actually in the register file, because this doesn't say so, for
example, if this load has been a little bit later, we would have to wait for it,
but because it's done, we can read 7.1 and put it here. And then we're going to
rename F10 to point to this ML2 which is where we put the divide. And that
concludes the issue for this cycle. Now as far as the dispatch is concerned,
we have already dispatched this load and there is nothing else that is ready to
dispatch, so we don't dispatch anything this cycle. In this cycle, this load is
still executing, it is going to broadcast as a result in the very next cycle,
in Cycle 6, and there is no result that gets broadcast in this cycle either,
so we are basically done with Cycle 5. Now let’s look at Cycle 6. In Cycle 6,
we are going to try to dispatch this ADD. There is a unit available, so
we will succeed in dispatching it. F8 and F2 are going to be AD1 and LD2,
rename F6 to point to the AD2 now which is where we put this instruction.
And that concludes the issuing of this instruction.
Now let's look at whether we can dispatch something. Well, in Cycle 5,
this instruction is still executing, so in Cycle 6 is going to write the result,
but until that writes the result, nothing is ready really to execute, so
basically we don't really dispatch anything, but there will be a right result by
the load. As a result of this, several things will happen. First of all,
we will deposit the result of the load, which is whatever is at address 245,
to the register F2. So, let's say that our F2 just became, I don't know,
minus 2.5. We can then provide this value also to all of the things that
are waiting for LD2. In this case there are several instructions, so
the operant here matches LD2. So, minus 2.5 will be captured here.
And, we are no longer waiting for it. The second operant of this
instruction also matches, but we are going to capture it here and mark this as
no longer waiting for it. And then the first operant of this matches it,
minus 2.5, so we are going to un-mark it here, too. And finally,
because this entry matches LD2, we are going to change the RAT to once
more point to the register file. So this concludes the writing of the result.
Remember that, because now these instructions are actually ready to go, but
because that happens kind of towards the end of the cycle,
we consider that they cannot really dispatch in the same cycle.
Because we are considering that we cannot first broadcast the result and
then dispatch instructions that use that result. It's easier if we then
first try to dispatch instructions and then broadcast the result,
because if we now consider what can dispatch, this looks like it can dispatch,
so we need to remember that the broadcast has happened in the same cycle, and
this really is not eligible for dispatch yet. So that's why we did, kind of,
dispatch before broadcast. Similarly, it would help if we just did the,
you know, dispatch and then issue, and then broadcast, just so
that, you know, kind of, we don't consider things that have just issued for
dispatch. But that's easy, because only one thing gets to dispatch and
it's very, very quick. So in Cycle 6, we have issued an instruction,
we have broadcast the result, and nothing really has been dispatched. So
now it's time to consider what happens in Cycle 7.